notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Nicolas dupontignan bonjour bonjour
monsieur vous êtes député de lessonne
député nonincrit et vous êtes président
du parti debout la France nous sommes
ensemble pendant une vingtaine de
minutes pour et bien un entretien en
partenariat avec la presse régionale qui
est représenté aujourd'hui par Stéphane
Vernet bonjour bonjour Alexandre bonjour
bonjour Stéphane Vernet directeur de la
rédaction de Ouest France à Paris alors
on va commencer par le sujet d'actualité
principale en France actuellement la
colère du monde agricole Gabriel Atal a
promis des annonces rapides cette
semaine après avoir rencontré le
syndicat la FNSEA et le syndicat des
jeunes agriculteurs comment selon vous
le gouvernement doit répondre à cette
crise agricole ce ne sont pas des
mesures de court terme dont on a besoin
bien bien sûr cela peut aider mais en
vérité les agriculteurs souffrent depuis
des années dans un silence
incroyable je proteste depuis des années
sur les conditions qui aujourd'hui les
étouff en fait c'est très simple d'un
côté l'Union européenne avec l'accord du
gouvernement français il faut pas faire
de l'Union européenne un bou émissaire
c'est le gouvernement français qui
approuve signe des accords de libre
échange et je suis surpris d'ailleurs
qu'on en parle très peu aujourd'hui des
accords de libre échange qui avec des
pays qui ne sont pas astreints aux
normes environnementales sociales
sanitairees que doivent respecter nos
agriculteurs et heureusement qu'il les
respectent d'ailleurs et puis de l'autre
côté la même Union européenne et le même
gouvernement français accable et durciss
ses normes au point même maintenant
d'interdire de cultiver 4 % de jacher
allant jusqu'à 10 % dans les prochaines
années ça veut dire qu'il y a quelque
chose d'insupportable pour nos
agriculteurs
c'est que d'un côté on ouvre les
frontières à des produits qui ne
respectent pas nos normes et de l'autre
on les accap de normes supplémentaires
et pire on organise la décroissance de
la production donc ça veut dire quoi
cela veut dire que l'Union européenne et
le gouvernement français ont décidé
quelque part consciemment de réduire la
production européenne pour importer de
l'extérieur moins cher à bas cou et à
mauvaise qualité environnementale c'est
un suicide et les agriculteurs n'ont pas
envie de disparaître à juste titre voilà
donc enfin il y a une réaction mais
c'est pas des petites mesurettes qui
vont changer quoi que ce soit quand vous
avez un accord avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
je prends un exemple précis déjà je
crois qu'on ne couvre que 58 % de notre
consommation de vin d'agneau et on va
importer sur 18000 km bonjour Le le coup
carbone 18000 km dans des SAES d'azote
liquide de l'agneau 30 % moins cherah on
tue une il voilà donc un moment il faut
arrêter alors on réagit pas tous de la
même manière par rapport à ce que ce que
propose ou ce qu'impose l'Union
européenne notamment à travers le Green
Deal quand vous parlez de de réduction
de la production là vous pensez plus
spécifiquement au Pays-Bas où le
gouvernement a décidé de réduire le
chaptel d'un/ers pour le pour les pour
les beau vins en fait mais en France on
n'est pas concerné on est pas sur le
même concerné j'ai il y a une volonté en
France de réduire la j'ai
amené j'ai apporté conditionnalité des
aides de la PAC 2023- 2027
issu du règlement UE du 2 décembre 2021
et cetera faut le lire pour le croire
vous avez 9
BCAE langage technocratique BCAE 8
maintient des éléments du paysage jaer
supérieur à 4 % des terres arables où
l'exploitation doit être consacré et
cetera ça veut dire que là c'est pas
nouveau les jchers non c'est nouveau
cette année puisque ça avait été
suspendu en 2022 et 2023 ça s'applique
cette année 2024 comment nos
agriculteurs peuvent accepter au moment
où il y a une pénurie alimentaire dans
le monde de voir une Union européenne
devenue complètement folle interdire de
cultiver vous vous rendez compte la
production agricole de céréales baisse
de 10 % par rapport aux 5 dernières
années alors il y a des aspects
climatiques bien sûr mais il y a surtout
qu'on interdit à des agriculteurs de
cultiver c'est comme vous si on vous
réduiseit votre émission on vous
interdit de faire votre métier et au
même moment on ouvre les vannes de
toutes les importations c'est criminel
donc finalement vraiment donc c'est
l'Union européenne c'est le gouvernement
français qui joue double jeu le
gouvernement français ment il fait
semblant de s'apitoyer enfin quand même
quand on vous écoute on a l'impression
que le gouvernement français veut tuer
l'agriculture en France vous un peu fort
là quandê'y vais pas fort il accepte ce
que fait Bruxelles l'idée du Green Deal
c'est quoi c'est de réduire la
production c'est la décroissance
agricole alors pas sur tous les sur tous
les produits et pas dans tous les
secteurs heureusement pas dans tous les
produits dans tous les secteurs il faut
stopper toutes les normes écologiques
pour l'agriculture et notamment la
hausse des taxes sur le gazol non
routier ah bien évidemment il faut
arrêter ce délire ce délire parce que
pourquoi alors on importe des produits
continue à subventionner le mais
heureusement oui pourquoi on importe des
prod il y a deux solutions soit vous
jouez sur les importations en arrêtant
d'importer des produits à des normes
environnementales et sanitaires
détestables je prends l'exemple et je
connais bien je suis président du groupe
d'amitié France-Brésil je connais bien
le Brésil que j'aime beaucoup mais
l'accord Mercosur très très gros
producteur de pesticidesou il vient
autoriser quatre nouveaux pesticides
strictement interdits en Europe donc
expliquez-moi la logique Environnmental
on précise que l'accord Mercosur
Emmanuel Macron a mis un gros coup de
frein sur sa ratification il y a une
grande ambigué d'Emmanuel Macron
actuellement l'accord Mercosur susp
attendez bon il nous avait dit ça sur le
CTA il est en application il a toujour
pas été ratifié donc ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il faut une cohérence dans la
vie si l'Union européenne dit il faut
mettre des norme supplémentaire
environnementale sur les agriculteurs
européens bah faut pas qu'au même moment
elle signe des accords avec des pays qui
aggravent et qui ont des pesticides
strictement interdits c'est typiquement
le cas des
néonicotinoïdes où en fait ils sont
interdits et il y a il y a un
certainombre de pays qui continuent à
les utiliser massivement et qui
importent leurs produits chez nous mais
ils seront interdit en 2000 ils seront
interdits en 2026 est-ce que c'est pas
aussi un problème de calendrier c'est la
fausse écologie on assassine nos
agriculteurs en leur dis disant tu as
pas le droit tu as pas le droit tu as
pas le droit et de l'autre côté on
applaudit et on facilite les
importations mais imaginez la révolte
des agriculteurs c'est pas cohérent soit
on applique des normes à nos
agriculteurs et on applique les mêmes
normes au produits importés soit on
applique pas on durcit pas les normes à
nos agriculteurs et on continue
d'importer mais on ne peut pas demander
le beurre l'argent du beurre et la
crémière enfin c'est insupportable pour
pour nos agriculteurs question politique
Nicolas dupontignon on a vu ce weekend
Jord Jordan Bardella le patron du RN
aller voir les agriculteurs en disant
euh comme vous hein que c'était la faute
de l'Europe de Macron finalement vous
êtes vous avez le même discours sur ce
mais totalement parce que c'est la
réalité et c'est pas la question
simplement de Jordane Bardella ou des
autres il y a deux catégories de
personnes dans la vie il y a ceux qui
font des coups en douce comme Emmanuel
Macron son ministre de l'Agriculture ils
font semblant de s'apitoyer sur les
agriculteurs ça fait des mois que les
agriculteurs protestent ça fait de mois
que pacifiquement ils essayent de se
faire entendre on est dans un pays quand
même extraordinaire il faut bloquer une
autoroute pour que les médias
s'attéressent à un problème et pour pour
que le gouvernement tout d'un coup
panique quel est ce pays où il faut
aller à une extrémité pour se faire
entendre face à une injustice parce que
c'est une injustice et il faut donc
supprimer la Commission de Bruxelles il
faut arrêter avec cette union européenne
totalement autoritaire non démocratique
c'est un enjeu majeur du 9 juin une
question d'ordre public et de sécurité
publique on vient d'apprendre qu'une
femme est décédée sur un blocage routier
organisé par les agriculteurs est-ce
qu'à un moment donné géralde Darmanin
qui le refuse pour le moment et bien
doit ordonner de déloger ses
agriculteurs et ses blocages routiers
pour l'instant on voit bien que va on
est dans la même situation qu'au moment
des gilets
jaunes incapacité à traiter un problème
abandon de la population française par
une oligarchie qui nous gouverne
totalement insensible à souffrance des
Français et qui aboutit obligatoirement
à des drame donc moi ce que je crois
c'est qu'il faut maintenant être très
clair est-ce que le gouvernement estès
très clair sur le refus d'appliquer le
Mercosur la dénonciation de certains
accords comme l'accord avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande le l'abandon de la
jachè l'abandon d'une Green Deal faut
être clair est-ce qu'on fait des faux
semblants à donner des des sucres d'orge
alors une exonération de ceci de cela ou
est-ce qu'on prend vraiment le problème
agricole français à sa juste mesure
parce que derrière la souffrance des
agricultures des agriculteurs il y a
l'autosuffisance alimentaire vous savez
que depuis 2019 nous sommes déficitaires
en produits agricoles bah c'est très
simple à force d'importer des produits
du bout du monde c'est anti-écologique
c'est mauvais pour notre santé c'est
mauvais pour notre taux de suffisance
alimentaire et on continue donc a un
moment il faut dire STOP mais pas faire
semblant donc il y a un choix les
Français devront choisir le 9 juin
Nicola duponign on va parler de la
hausse du prix de l'électricité qui a
été confirmée dimanche soir par le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Lemer une
hausse entre 8,6 % et 9,8 % à partir du
mois de février c'est la fin du bouclier
énergétique dont on bénéficie
les Français c'est une mesure
responsable pour redresser nos finances
publiques non mais ça c'est le discours
de Monsieur le Maire qui est une
provocation d'abord les prix ont
augmenté de 39 % en 1 an 44 % en 2 ans
exactement c'est considérable prix de
l'électricité oui c'est considérable
pour nos concitoyens je croyais que
Gabriel hatal avait été nommé pour aider
les classes moyennes ça commence bien ça
montte l'hypocrisie totale de ce grand
cinéma qu'on a eu autour du 1er janvier
et le bouclier tarifaire quand même
quand même mais le bouclier tarifaire
euh il a permis d'amortir ses
augmentations mais il a permis d'amortir
quelque chose de scandaleux parce que
s'il y a une telle augmentation c'est
parce que on a un prix européen de
l'électricité et que le prix français
est aligné sur l'harmonisation sur le
prix du gaz allemand il y a deux pays
parce qu'on me dit oui vous pouvez pas
et cetera monsieur le maire dit ou on
est en train de réformer ce système non
mais attendez il y a deux pays qui sont
sortis du Prix européen qui ne font pas
oui l'Espagne et le Portugal d'accord
pourquoi parce que ils ont la chance de
produire uneélectricité moins cher nous
sommes exactement dans la même situation
aussi en bout de chaîne par rapport au
attendez nous sommes il y a des
interconnexions alors je vais répondre
là-dessus mais d'abord nous produisons
une électricité nucléaire deux fois
moins cher que le prix européen pourquoi
on n profite pas pourquoi on interdit
aux Français aux entreprises françaises
aux Français d'en profiter donc il av
pas besoin de bouclier qui coûter une
fortune si on a été sorti du marché
européen comme l'Espagne et le Portugal
qu'on avait appliqué nos coû de
production et on aurait eu un avantage
comparatif énorme par rapport aux autres
pays européens grâce à l'électricité
nucléaire exactement Monsieur le Maire
et j'ai dit que c'était de la haute
trahison a préféré servir les intérêts
allemands que les intérêts français mais
mais là en l'occurrence les prix du
marché sont revenus un petit peu à la
norme c'est la question de la taxe du
gouvernement mais je sais mais Monsieur
le Maire préfère servir les intérêts
allemands que les intérêts français je
le pèse mes mots c'est de la haute
trahison je l'ai dit il y a 6 mois
moralité on a étouffé les entreprises
françaises on a dépensé des fortunes au
budget pour ce fameux bouclier et
maintenant on le réduit mais il faut
traiter la cause sortir du marché
européen alors là il y a un argument que
dit Monsieur le Maire je préfère y
répondre que vous avez dit il y a un
instant oui mais si on sort du marché
européen il y aura plus d'interconnexion
c'est complètement faux nous sommes avec
l'Angleterre avec des interconnexions il
y a tous les jours de l'électricité qui
passe sous la Manche et pourtant nous
sommes pas dans un
marché de prix commun c'est distinct
vous pouvez avoir des interconnexions
vendre et acheter l'électricité au prix
du marché mais vous pouvez garantir un
prix unique mais pour ça il faut sortir
de cette usine à gaz qu'on a créé d'un
prix du système privé il faut revenir à
un prix national ce que j'ai proposé à
la présidentielle ce que je propose sans
cesse
EDF a été nationaliser il faut un seul
opérateur il faut un seul prix
réglementer et il faut se baser sur nos
coûts de production et là vous verrez
qu'on qu'on évitera toutes ces histoires
qu'on donnera du pouvoir d'achat à nos
concitoyens on aidera nos entreprises et
on sera autonome voilà c'est très simple
en fait ce sujet autre actualité sur le
pouvoir d'achat les franchises médicales
vont doubler à partir du mois de mars
est-ce que comme Emmanuel Macron vous
pensez que c'est une mesure de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la sécurité
sociale alors je vais être obligé de
critier parce qu'on a on a aujourd'hui
il faut reconnaître c'est c'est une
avalanche de mesures
ahurissante la franchise enfin quand
même 800 millions pour trouver 800
millions moi j'ai écrit un livre
valpognon je recommande je fais ma pub à
l'archipel j'ai trouvé 50 milliards
d'économie 800 millions vous savez ce
que c'est c'est 10 % de la fraude à la
carte vitale Vous avez une sénatrice ici
madame Goulet qui a écrit un très bon
rapport euh 10 % l'aide médicale d'État
pour les clandestin c'est plus d'un
milliard d' il faut pas la supprimer
entièrement bien sûr mais on peut faire
des économies les retraites payées à
l'étranger à des morts c'est à peu près
1 milliard sur 6 milliards et demi donc
ce que je trouve insupportable et là
pour les Français qui sont écœurés c'est
que les gens honnêtes qui respectent nos
lois qui sont Français vont payer en
plus et vous savez on voit d'ailleurs
que
Emmanuel Macron viv vit sur un autre
dans un autre monde parallèle vous savez
1 € pour une boîte de médicament quand
vous êtes au SMIC et que vous finissez
pas la fin de mois et que le 20in vous
avez plus rien pour manger ça paraît
bête mais 1 € plus 2 € sur l'acte c'est
beaucoup et la conséquence de tout ça
c'est que pour 800 millions d'économie
qu'on pourrait faire ailleurs il s'agit
pas de creuser c'est le trou on va
induire des non consommations au moment
où on peut soigner et éviter des
maladies plus graves c'est abérrant pour
la sécurité sociale vraiment je
comprends pas comment on peut prendre
une mesure aussi antisociale au moment
où il y a tant de pauvreté dans notre
pays c'est pour moi extrêmement choquant
extrêmement choquant vous venez juste de
dire il faut on peut il faut pas creuser
le trou j'imagine que vous parlez du
trou de la sécum mais il y a pas que ça
il y a quel quel regard vous portez sur
l'état des finances publiques de ce pays
bah il dramatique d'abord il y a quand
même la nécessité de trouver des moyens
moyens de faire de nouvelles économies
on on est quand même dos au mur
aujourd'hui bien sûr vous avez raison la
première économie on donne 10 milliards
d'euros net à l'Union européenne pour
des normes aberrentes donc moi je veux
faire une économie là-dessus sous
Jacques Chirac et Lionel jusp on donnait
1 milliard ils étaient pas
anti-européens on donne 10 milliards et
ça va monter 15 20 c'est colossal donc
on fait une économie là-dessus ensuite
on fait une économie sur les fausses
cartes vitales on peut avoir 10
milliards mais disant allez 5 tout de
suite on fait des économies sur le coup
de l'immigration on fait des économies
sur les gaspillages et il y en a dans
notre pays mais pas sur l'acte de se
soigner des gens les plus modestes qui
vont renoncer à des soins parce qu'ils
ne pourront pas payer d'ailleurs je
trouve indécent l'argument de
renonciation à des soins c'est ce que
souvent le gouvernement dit sur les
étrangers ah vous pouvez pas toucher
parce qu'ils vont renoncer à se soigner
donc les étrangers ont le droit de se
soigner dans notre pays mais pas les
Français c'est le monde à l'en en
franchement pour moi c'est le monde à
l'envers il y a des économies à faire
bien sûr il faut les faire tiens il y a
une grande économie à faire c'est les
intérêts vous savez qu'on continue à
emprunter à taux variable sur
l'inflation le service de la dette oui
10 % par de la dette c'est une
aberration puisque les taux d'intérêt
coûtent très cher le Sénat a ajouté 12
milliards 12 milliards Nicolas DUP
dépense pour payer ça on va on va
aborder une question international on va
parler de la guerre en Ukraine puisque
la France va livrer à l'Ukraine 6 canons
César 40 missiles scalp est-ce que armé
l'Ukraine ce n'est pas la seule solution
pour repousser l'armée russe hors du
territoire ukrainien non je suis
totalement hostile à ses livraisons je
trouve que c'est pas moral de d'armer un
pays sans combattre si Emmanuel Macron
est cohérent bah il va combattre en
Ukraine bon courage Bonne Chance et les
Français ne le voudront pas et qu'il os
demander au français au moins au
Parlement mais armer les gens pour les
laisser se faire tuer et c'est pour les
protéger non on les protège pas on est
en train de faire disparaître l'Ukraine
par une guerre par procuration amorale
c'est trop facile soit on intervient en
Ukraine et j'y suis hostile soit on
donne pas des armes pour que un peuple
disparaisse parce qu'on entretient un
conflit de manière scandaleuse mais si
vous n'armez pas l'Ukraine vous laissez
les chars russes tranquillement
conquérir le pays un accord à avoir avec
la Russie que je réclame depuis le
départ qui était possible zevanski est
un régime corrompu qui alimente la
guerre sous la pression des Américains
qui sont ravis de voir l'Europe
s'écrouler nous payons notre gaz quatre
fois plus cher nous sommes en crise
économique nous sommes en crise agricole
alors qu'un accord était possible en
Ukraine un accord simple
démilitarisation de l'Ukraine neutralité
de l'Ukraine retrait des troupes russes
et autonomie du donbas c'est ce que
demande la Russie c'est un compromis
possible la Russie veut plus bien sûr il
faut pas tout lui donner mais il faut un
accord de paix de toute façon cet accord
de paix viendra très vite car c'est
monstrueux ce qu'on est en train de
faire en Ukraine un peuple est en train
de disparaître de souffrir on alimente
pour vendre nos armements et on sait
très bien qu'à la fin il faudra un
accord avec la Russie donc faire croire
que la Russie va disparaître comme ça
par enchantement alors même que les tort
sur ce conflit contrairement à ce qu'on
a dit sont partagés il y a une faute
russe que j'ai condamné bien sûr mais le
donbas est une zone proche de la Russie
il fallait trouver un compromis
d'autonomie mais vous pensez vraiment
qu'on peut avoir un dialogue bien
évidemment mais bien évidemment et
encore vous vous êtes un des RARs dans
la classe politique à tenir ce discours
et j'assume parce que moi je ne cache
pas mes sentiments précis je pense que
les tors sont partagés je pense que ce
conflit est la ruine de l'Europe je
pense que ce conflit favorise les
États-Unis et la Chine et signe la
disparition de l'Europe au 21e siècle et
que nous sommes en train de tomber dans
un piège bien sûr que c'est horrible
bien sûr que j'ai condamné bien sûr
qu'il faut dire à la Russie stop
attention mais vous cez ça va suffire de
dire stop attention à la
Russie voulez vous venez vous-même de
dire à l'instant que on peut négocier
avec la Russie mais il faut pas tout lui
donner mais où çaarê o s'arrêtera
Vladimir Poutine après l'Ukraine c'est
quoi c'est les États baltes c'est la
Finlande c'est
laagin vous croyez vous
imaginez bien évidemment c'est une fable
on voit que vous ne connaissez pas
l'Ukraine qui l'Ukraine a été pendant
400 ans
russe la parti de l'Ukraine 400 ans cet
état est indépendant cet état pour vous
il a pas il y a pas de volonté il y a
pas de volonté hgémonique expansioniste
de Vladimir Poutine et de toute façon
nous avons les moyens avec le temps de
l'arrêter parce avons les moyens temp de
l'arrêter et alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe qu'est-ce qui se passe si Donald
Trump gagne les élections américaines il
a dit qu' il arrêtera ce conflit ah non
mais il a surtout dit qu'il voulait plus
il voulait plus venir au secours de
l'Europe il était plus question que les
États-Unis défendent l'Europe voulait
plus mettre il l'a dit il l'a dit à
plusieurs reprise il a dit qu'il il ne
voulait plus de l'OTAN il voulait plus
de l'Alliance atlantique est-ce que nous
on est prêt à assurer notre défense au
niveau européen face à l'appé des niveau
français nous avons la force des
dissuasions nous sommes là pour défendre
la France nous sommes pas là pour
défendre toute l'Europe nous avons une
force de dissuasion nucléaire pour la
France parallèlement l'OTAN qui existe
est tout à fait capable de défendre avec
les Polonais les Français les Allemands
l'OTAN en revanche l'Ukraine est un cas
à part qui était une zone anciennement
république soviétique et où il faut un
compromis Jacques Chirac jairac avait
proposé à l'époque avait proposé une
zone neutre en Ukraine un donbas
autonome et c'était le moyen de faire la
paix durable en Europe les Américains
ont refusé et se servent aussi de
l'Ukraine comme un moyen de déstabiliser
la Russie c'est une folie il ne faut ni
donner raison russes ni aux Ukrainiens
et je pense que ce serait
l'honneur ce serait l'honneur de la
France de proposer une paix durable car
je vous assure que c'est la mort
économique et sociale du continent
européen ce conflit alors Nicolas
dupontignan ce conflit sera un des
grands thèmes de la campagne des
élections européennes vous avez annoncé
et bien la présentation d'une liste de
Bou la France dans cette campagne
européenne vous l'amènerez cette liste
on verra il y aura une personnalité je
l'espère qui l'amènera ça sera décidé
très prochainement et vous serez informé
pourquoi on a décidé de faire une liste
quel est l'intérêt d'une liste de Bou à
France alors qu'il y a déjà une liste
souverainiste en tête des sondages celle
du rassemblement national mais parce que
debout la France a un projet très précis
et va au bout des choses nous voulons
mettre fin à l'Union européenne nous
voulons reconstruire une Europe des
nations libres et des projets concrets
nous voulons la fin de la Commission
européenne euh nous voulons la sortie du
marché européen nous voulons le
rétablissement des frontières nationales
nous voulons bref un programme très
précis le frxit c'est pas le frxit
puisqu'on le fera pas seul ce que nous
voulons là le frxit c'est une décision
nationale c'est l'élection
présidentielle là ce que nous voulons
c'est envoyer au Parlement européen des
gens qui ont les idées claires et qui ne
renonc en rien à leur projet moi je vois
que dans tous les pays d'Europe il y a
des personnalités qui disent maintenant
ça suffit c'est si je devais prendre une
image que j'ai prise l'Union européenne
d'aujourd'hui c'est un immeuble de
copropriétaire l'immeuble est squatté on
a enlevé les portes et les fenêtres il y
a une Commission de Bruxelles qui décide
de la vie des des habitants de tout
c'est plus possible moi je veux qu'on
déménage et qu'on passe dans un
loottissement de maison individuelle
chacun sa maison sa clôture son jardin
son terrain et des coopérations à la
carte c'est pas le mais finalement
l'Europe des nations le rassemblement
national le propose aussi écoutez sur le
prog diff Jordan Bardella a dit qu'il
restait dans l'Union européenne très
clairement moi je pense qu'il faut là
maintenant dire STOP définitivement on
ne peut pas continuer à obéir à Madame
Van derleyen donc vous proposez bien une
sortie de l'Union européne je propose
une sortie collective à plusieurs pays
de l'Union européenne pour reconstruire
une Europe des nations c'est simple je
ne propose pas la sortie britannique on
part tout seul je propose d'envoyer des
députés européens qui vont prendre
contact avec les autres députés
européens pour faire une Europe
alternative qui soit l'Europe des
nations celle du général de Gaulle de
corand denower où on était capable de
faire Airbus on était capable de faire
Arian mais ça passait pas par la
Commission de Bruxelles je pense qu'on
ne peut plus continuer à faire des
compromis avec la Commission de
Bruxelles et donc je pense qu'il faut
une liste européenne qui a un langage
clair très clair et et je pense que les
Français l'attendent et puis entre nous
c'est un scrutin proportionnel on veut
nous enfermer dans un duel
uniquement Renaissance enfin macroniste
RN c'est le seul scrutin proportionnel
c'est le seul scrutin proporessionnel où
les Français ont le choix on se plaint
qu'il y a un grand danger
d'abstention à l'élection européenne
vous le savez moins de 50 % des votants
bah sil y a que deux listes et que tout
le monde doit se regrouper derrière
chaque liste bah il y aura pas de
diversité il y aura pas de choix nous
nous allons offrir un choix et je pense
que ce sera le bienvenu la dernière fois
il y avait pas eu de listes il y en
avait eu 34 vous la vôre avait obtenu
3,51 % des surres exprimés qui vous avez
pas permis d'avoir de de députés europé
cette fois-ci nous en et vous étiez
proche des 3 % quelle se fatidique
audelà en ça duquel les les les les
frais de campagne les dépenses
électorales sont pas remboursé Mo je
fais debout la France que V partie peut
encaisser peut encaisser ça je fais de
la politique pour défendre des idées
dans un monde de communication je je
sais que ça pe paraître anachronique
mais je crois que les Français justement
sont écœurés de la vie politique parce
qu'on l'a vu avec ce remanimement ce
n'est qu'image artifice de communication
nous on a un projet européen il est
clair il sera écrit on le soumet au
français et bien il y aura des alliances
possibles avec d'autres
mouvements je n'en sais rien vous savez
pasquis Villier ça s'est fait
souvenez-vous il y a longtemps 2 mois
avant donc on verra moi je parle d'un
projet un projet clair dans un monde ti
évescant où les idées changent évoluent
ù tout n'est qu'image et ben nous c'est
carré et puis les Français onuront le
choix et puis après ils font ce qu'ils
veul et ben ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Nicolas
duuponignan d'avoir été notre invité
politique ce matin merci Stéphane on va
revoir la Une de West France qui est
consacré à cette crise agricole
agriculteur en colère ce qu'il demande
tout de suite le club des territoires